persona 'non grata' así declaró el
gobierno venezolano a la embajadora de
la unión europea en caracas como
respuesta a las nuevas sanciones que el
bloque europeo impuso contra el país
socialista esta semana ahora la
diplomática isabel brillante tiene 72
horas para abandonar el país y otros
cuatro diplomáticos europeos en caracas
han recibido avisos en contra del fallo
de bruselas se le da un plazo de 72
horas para abandonar el territorio
venezolano y lo hacemos
porque las circunstancias así lo exigen
lo hacemos porque van ya 55 decisiones
eso que llaman en la unión europea o en
el sistema estadounidense sanciones como
si tuviesen ellos alguna autoridad moral
que no la tienen ni tampoco legal para
imponer castigo alguno a ciudadanos de
cualquier otro país que no sean del
propio territorio de la unión europea la
unión europea lamentó la decisión del
ejecutivo venezolano y dijo que el
movimiento sólo contribuía al
aislamiento de la nación sudamericana
el bloqueo europeo decidió imponer
nuevas sanciones como el congelamiento
de bienes e impedimentos de viajes
contra 19 oficiales venezolanos que
incluyen a la vicepresidenta delfín
rodríguez y al segundo al mando del
gobierno diosdado cabello
la razón socavar la democracia y cometer
abusos contra los derechos humanos todo
a raíz de las elecciones a la asamblea
nacional del pasado diciembre en las que
ganó maduro pero que ni la unión europea
ni eeuu reconocen en medio de una
profunda crisis económica y social
maduro se ha mostrado abierto a negociar
con la unión europa
para levantar las sanciones que calificó
de crueles e injustas no obstante esta
decisión aleja la posibilidad de futuras
conversaciones entre caracas y bruselas